I'll start over the story.
When I was 24 years old, I remember getting pulled over in Riesel, Texas.
The reason why I remember getting pulled over in Riesel, Texas, of all places, it's funny to say that and to watch some of you look at each other like him, too, because many of us have found ourselves pulled over in Riesel, Texas.
The reason why I remember it
even though it was so long ago, is at that time, I was living in college station, and yet I was driving here to Dallas to see Brooke, who was then just my girlfriend, is now my wife, and yet motivated by love.
I might have been speeding a little bit, you know?
I was driving quick down the highway, and as I came to Riesel, I passed over a hill, and there, low and behold, was an officer waiting for someone, the likes of,
You know, and so he pulled me over and as we kind of went through the normal shindig, I knew the standard operating procedure.
I went ahead and I grabbed my license and registration and I prepared to confess to him all of my sins and take my ticket and move on with my merry day.
And yet what I realized is this was no normal pullover because he was not just going to send me on after giving me a ticket and said he handed me a pamphlet entitled alive at 25.
And the reason this pamphlet was so interesting is because it was
different than the normal way of processing a ticket in the state of Texas.
You see, for most counties in the state of Texas, when you get a speeding ticket, you just merely pay the ticket, hop online, work through a defensive driving course, and you're done.
You know, you've atoned for your sins.
And yet, Riesel was one of the only counties in the great state of Texas that required a little bit more.
You see,
They required that you would actually show up to an in-person interactive day-long national safety and driver education course.
Which just felt crazy to me because I was one just going eight miles per hour over the speed limit.
It's not like I was risking anybody's life.
And also I was 24.
I was so close to being alive at 25.
I couldn't even cut me a break.
And yet in this moment, I knew
My destiny was set.
I had to spend an entire day at the local police office, and I had to watch poorly edited safety videos and eat stale bags of check mix all while grieving my state of affairs.
You know what it's like to be in this situation, not because you went through a Live at 25, though it looks like many of you are a Live at 25, but because you know what it's like to have a punishment that doesn't fit the crime.
You know, maybe it's a small thing.
Maybe you just decided to have that iced coffee after dinner with some people that were going to go have some.
Now you're awake at 3.49 in the morning and you're reliving every major decision you've made since 2015.
Maybe it's not that.
Maybe for you, you just wanted to
make a good relationship with a co-worker and you know humor is the way into everyone's heart and so you decide to test out the waters of sarcasm with this individual and yet what you find is without any emoji support they totally misunderstood you and you now find yourself writing out a three paragraph long explanation and apology
trying to make sure that they don't hate you.
Maybe someone looked at you and asked you to come out and you just politely, you politely disregarded and told him that you had something else to do and said, and yet you're now worried that everyone there never wants to spend any time with you ever again.
You see, it could be something as small as that, but oftentimes it's not so small.
You see, for many of us, we've found ourselves in moments that have really mattered.
You were a good person.
You only ever did right by people.
But now you're the one that's dealing with chronic illness, you're the one that's riddled with mental health disorder while everyone else in your life is achieving the things that you wanted to achieve later on.
Maybe you went to school, you studied hard, you didn't go out and party, instead you made a great effort for the kind of future you wanted and you walked that stage having graduated summa cum laude and yet you entered into a horrible job market
You found yourself as an overqualified barista and every single evening you're constantly slipping in applications on LinkedIn because you're trying to make your way out and take care of that mountain of school debt that you know you are racked with.
Maybe that's not the case for you.
Maybe instead you got the kind of job that you wanted.
You're actually embarking upon a great career.
You have spent a considerable amount of time establishing yourself in your industry, ensuring that you reach financial sustainability.
And yet though you have given all of your time to that, you've looked
up ready to begin a family and what you realize is time has passed you by.
The dating pool has emptied and you're actually single longer than you ever thought you would be.
What do you do when that's the case?
When nothing goes right, when everything goes wrong, when you did everything you could, but nothing has gone like it should.
When you look up and it feels like everything everyone says about God is in fact not true.
When they say he is good, all you can think is he's holding a grudge.
What do you do when that's the case?
What do you do when it feels like God is punishing you?
That's the question that we're going to try to answer to not because that's the question that is asked in the passage that we're looking at together, which is in Genesis chapter six.
So if you get a Bible, go ahead and grab it and turn with me to Genesis chapter six.
While you're doing that, we've been in the series where we've been looking at the 10 most iconic moments in the
over the course of the book of Genesis.
And the reason we've been doing that is because at the beginning of the year, we thought there was no better place to begin than with the book of beginnings.
And so we hopped into Genesis, but knowing we can't read all 50 chapters, we thought we could look at these little vignettes, these pictures that are significant in the overall storyline of Genesis so that way we could learn a little bit about who God is.
You see the book of Genesis is important because it outlines for us many of the foundational
answers to many of life's philosophical questions.
It tells us, who's God?
What's gone wrong?
Who are you?
Do you have a purpose?
Is there life after death?
What do we do in relationship to one another?
Genesis is answering all of these deeply existential and philosophical questions.
And as we've made our way through it, looking at many of the iconic stories, we find ourselves here tonight looking at what is widely considered the most iconic story in the book of Genesis.
Any guesses?
You cheated because you're in Genesis 6 and you've already seen it for yourself.
We are in fact looking at Noah and the flood.
The reason it's so popular, so iconic is because we grew up, many of us reading about this.
Like our mind goes to so many different directions for some of you.
It takes you back to Sunday school.
Sitting in class, looking at that flannel graph.
observing all of the beautiful photos of this big wooden boat with the zoo full of animals aboard.
For others of you, it's not Sunday school that you harken back to.
Instead, you just think of how maniacal the whole story actually feels.
You think of the whole world being covered in water, and you know that people are running for their life, and you think of this lunatic god that is laughing at humanity's demise.
You know, others of you, that's not the case.
You think what Hollywood thinks.
Russell Crowe in like an army of rock monsters united together to fight against the treachery of men.
Still not sure how they landed on that one for that movie, but the truth of the matter is we all go different directions whenever this story comes to mind.
And it's not just those of us here in this room.
If you look across the globe, if you consider the halls of history, you'll find that this story is actually known in something like 10 to 20 major cultures.
You see,
Whether it was the epic of Gilgamesh from ancient Mesopotamia, or the Sumerian flood story, or Dukalian, and the Pirra from Greek mythology, or Manu, and the great flood from Hinduism, what we know is that there are different cultures all throughout history that have their own rendition of this flood motif.
And so it raises
Not just in the minds of the people here, but it raises in the minds of people everywhere, a very common question that all of these stories have varying differences, which is simply, why is God so angry?
You ever wondered that?
And if you have, maybe you've thought to yourself, is he angry with me?
We're gonna unpack that idea as we work through this story.
This story is four chapters long.
It spans from six, seven, eight, and nine, which means we don't have time to read all of it all the way through.
And yet we're gonna look at certain moments that are particularly helpful for us as we try to evaluate is God in fact punishing us.
So we're just gonna dive in and we're gonna get after it.
Look at Genesis six starting in verse five with me.
It says this, the Lord saw that the wickedness of man was great in the earth.
That every intention of the thoughts of his heart was only
evil continually.
And the Lord regretted that he'd made man on the earth, and he grieved him to his heart.
And so the Lord said, I will blot out man whom I've created from the face of the land, man and animals and creeping things in birds of the heavens from sorry that I made them.
But Noah found favor in the eyes of the Lord.
Now, this is really just a set up to the rest of the flood narrative that is going to follow.
It takes virtually no time just in reading this to feel all of the melodramatic tendencies, the flair of this story from the very beginning.
Because from the punch, God declares that He will blot out man whom He created from the face of the land.
Which, as we read that, can feel a little bit like an overreaction, can it?
Like, there's no talk about God putting mankind into some kind of rehabilitation program.
He doesn't give us 10 steps to becoming a better you.
He doesn't send them to therapy for all of their issues.
Instead, for all intents and purposes, he just looks at them and says, hey, times run out, you're out of second chances, and I'm going to move on and do something different.
But if that's all we see, if we just treat this story like God's angry, he's just gonna push this massive reset button than what we're doing,
is we're not reading very carefully.
You see, one of the reasons we often believe God is punishing us is because, and this is your first point, we fail to realize that God is slower to anger than we are to blame.
You see, often we think that God is punishing us because we fail to realize God is slower to anger than we are to blame.
And the evidence of this is actually all
over the Bible.
And it does not waste any time describing this truth beginning in Genesis.
You see, we see the very first evidence of it in this passage specifically.
It says that God is slowed anger right here because although this is the first story in which we see God actually express emotion, the emotion he expresses is not anger.
It's sorrow.
That's the very first emotional expression we get from God.
It says that he was grieved in his heart, which is important because it tells us that God is not bloodthirsty over humanity because of their sin.
It tells us that God is broken-hearted over humanity because of their sin.
That's the first evidence we get to this truth that God is slow to anger, not quick, as many people assume him to be.
But it's not just that.
The second evidence is not in this chapter.
It's in the chapter previously and it's hard to pick up.
It's a very subtle detail.
You probably would not know it if someone did not tell it to you because I didn't know it until someone told it to me.
And yet though we don't understand it because we speak English to the ancient Israelite audience to whom this was originally written in red, they would have picked it up like that.
You see, in Genesis chapter five, what you find is all of Noah's ancestral heritage.
It's a long genealogy.
It's one of those things that you typically skim through if not skip all the way over.
And yet, what we do when we do that is we put ourselves in a position where we can miss something important.
There's several things that actually get unpacked in that genealogy that are significant.
Not in my notes, but I think it's valuable for you to know.
There's a story of Noah's great grandfather, a guy by the name of Enoch.
And what you see is that he walked with God and then God took him before he ever knew death.
You don't know what's fascinating about Enoch.
He was a third of the life of everybody else that lived during his day.
He was the ancient equivalent of a 30-year-old in our modern moment.
He was only 300, not 900.
And so what we see in Enoch is that it does not take long even in your young life.
You can walk with God in such a way that he looks at it.
And he says, you know what?
It's getting bad out of here, isn't it?
Let's get out of here.
That's possible.
Crazy to think that that's true.
And yet what we see is just one leg down from Enoch.
We meet a guy by the name of Methuselah.
And what's interesting about a Methuselah is his name means
When I die, judgment, which is massive when we consider that God is in fact slow to anger because when you look at Methuselah, what you see is when he did die, judgment actually did come.
That's when the flood began.
So how old is our guy Methuselah?
He is 969 years old.
He is the longest living human in history.
which is meaningful, because what it tells us is God is looking at this guy, he's saying, I am declaring to your life, that when you declare to the world, through your life, that when you go, everyone goes as well.
And so I'm gonna stretch your life out as long as possible, because I want people to repent and believe.
Isn't that amazing?
God is slow to anger.
We see in 2 Peter 3, 9, the Lord is not slow to fulfill His promise as some count, slowness, but He's patient toward you, not wishing that any should perish, but that all should reach repentance.
That's the second evidence.
And in the third evidence that we get for God being slow to anger actually isn't even found in the book of Genesis.
It's fascinating.
50 chapters in the book of Genesis, and yet God's anger, though alluded to, is never actually spoken explicitly about.
Which is crazy when you consider the events of Genesis.
We've already read some of them.
Like, Adam and Eve, they betray God.
Take of the fruit of good and evil, and they rebel, and yet God is not angry with them explicitly.
You move from that, and you go to Cain and Abel.
Cain murders his brother.
And yeah, we don't see God respond angrily towards Cain.
You go from there, and you find yourself here.
You go from here, and you go to the next story, and you see yourself looking at the tower of Babel.
And yet God has no anger in that story.
Either you move out of that, and you go to Sodom and Gomorrah.
And what you find is, though the people are doing some really crazy things, God's anger doesn't appear
quite clearly there.
Either you move out of that and you go to Abraham and you see that he trades his wife into Pharaoh so that way he can get favor while in Egypt and yet we don't see anger there.
You move out of that and you keep going and you find yourself looking at the life of Jacob and what happens in Jacob's life is he betrays his brother and robbed him of his inheritance and yet there's not necessarily anger for him there either.
You go past that and you see that you've got
Joseph, Joseph is sold by his brothers into slavery, and yet there's no anger there either.
All throughout Genesis, these crazy, heinous acts from mankind.
God is not explicitly, again, implicitly, you can see this, save your email, but explicitly, you don't see that he is angry.
Again and again and again, you see, he's merciful.
And yet the first time we see his anger explicitly articulated isn't until the Book of Exodus.
And then three times it's spoken of, each of which we see the evidence of his patient endurance with us in the midst of our frustrating behavior.
We see it with Moses, that very first demonstration of God's anger when he comes in.
He calls Moses to go into free Israel out of Egyptian bondage.
And yet Moses, he objects to the call on God's life.
Not once, not twice.
But it takes five objections before God is finally like, enough.
That's finally when he reaches his boiling point.
If you move from there to the second time in Exodus, you see, it's when Pharaoh refused to let God's people go.
And yet God didn't get mad after the first plague, the second plague, the third plague.
It took 10 before God finally felt anger towards Pharaoh.
And then the last one is we see, is that Mount Sinai?
Whenever God has led Israel out and it is in their moment of betrothal, they're making a covenant to one another.
And yet as God is working out the details with Moses, Israel in their darkest moment betrays him by worshiping a golden calf.
You see, it takes a lot to evoke God's anger.
God's wrath is rarely in a rush, which is important for us because though he is,
Though he is angry, he is slow to anger as Exodus 34 tells us.
It tells us this, that the Lord passed before him talking about Moses, introducing himself and proclaimed, I'm the Lord, the Lord, I've gotten merciful and gracious, slowed anger, abounding his steadfast love and faithfulness.
So here's the crazy thing about it.
God, so slowed anger is so slowed anger with you and I.
And yet we're so quick to anger with Him.
We are so quick to become frustrated because it's taking you longer to get the job that you want or to get the relationship that you want or to get better when you've been bad or to actually move on from that situation.
And because it is taking you longer than you expected, you grow frustrated with Him and you accuse Him of acting too slow.
Maybe it's not that.
Maybe you're annoyed that your actual life doesn't look as good as all the edited versions of other people's lives on social media.
And so what you feel is like God is being unjust.
He's being unfair to you.
He's been good to them, but he hasn't been good to you.
And so you accuse him of being unjust.
Maybe it's not that.
Maybe you, you're irritated that your friend or your family member or even you yourself are constantly gripped by some sort of health issue.
And so you look at God and what you do is you accuse him of being unkind, unloving, uncaring.
And yet here's the crazy thing.
Though we often perceive God as angry with us in reality, we are angry with him instead.
He hasn't given us what we want, who we want, where we want, how we want it.
And so like little entitled spoiled children, we accuse him of being indifferent to our life, insensitive to our needs, which is insane.
Because when you think about it,
There isn't an ounce of God that has proven to be insensitive to your need.
And the reason we know it is you can look at Christ.
You can see in Jesus the ultimate sensitivity to your need that you cannot save yourself.
And so he would enter into a rebellious world and live a faithful life for the sake of a people that were unfaithful to him.
God does not demonstrate in any kind of way an indifference to us.
But he said we see his intentionality in that he moves close to us and he actually lives a lot if you can't, dies the death you deserve and rises forth in victory, beating death by death itself.
We see in Jesus the personification of everything we often accuse God is not consistent with.
You see, we have to understand God, he is slowed anger.
but we too often are quick to blame.
And so if you feel like God is punishing you, it's worth considering.
Does he deserve your accusation?
That's the first thing.
Second thing, let's keep going.
Look at chapter six, verses nine and 10.
It says, these are the generations of Noah.
Noah was a righteous man, blameless in his generation.
Noah walked with God.
And Noah had three sons, Shim Ham,
And as you keep reading through that chapter, it gives you all the details on the arch's construction.
Verse 22 tells us this, Noah did this.
He did everything that God commanded him.
And then you go to chapter seven, and it says this, or can you verse one,
Then the Lord said to Noah, go into the ark, you and all your household.
I have seen that you are righteous before me in this generation.
Take with you seven pairs of all clean animals.
The male and his mate and the pair of the animals that are not clean.
The male and his mate and seven pairs of the birds of the heaven also.
Male and female to keep their offspring alive on the face of all the earth.
For in seven days, I will send rain on the earth 40 days and 40 nights.
And every living thing that I've made, I will blot out from the face of the ground.
And Noah did all that the Lord had commanded him.
I can't help but read this and put myself in Noah's shoes, which is worth doing whenever you find yourself kind of reading and working your way through a narrative portion of scripture.
You see, it's crazy.
When you consider what God has actually asked Noah to do, it's unfathomable.
Like God has looked at Noah and he has told him to build an ark on dry land.
Nowhere remotely close to water.
And yet, Moses, Noah chooses to go for it.
And it's not just that he chooses to build this arc.
It's also a Herculean effort that is of epic proportion, like this arc, if we were to bring it into our modern measurement would be 450 feet long, 75 feet wide, 45 feet tall.
And because it's a triple decker, it's got somewhere close to 95,000 square feet of total space to stand on.
It's a big sundeck, you know?
And yet what you know is that Noah chooses to go for it.
even though it takes him at the very least 50, but more than likely anywhere from 100 to 120 years total to complete the total project.
And so if you're in Noah's shoes, if you're considering his way in the world, how do you think people are engaging with this guy?
It's never even rained on the earth.
And he's building a boat.
There's not a ramp around.
I don't see a trailer for it.
That was smart.
Noah is not just controversial to the people around him.
He's crazy to the people around him.
And the craziest part of it all is it's all God's fault.
God is the one that asks Noah to do this.
He's the one to ask Noah to commit social suicide.
He's the one that told him to risk his reputation.
He's the one that has made him a local laughingstock to everybody in his hometown.
How could God do that?
That feels so unkind.
Here's how, because walking with God can be costly at times.
Walking with God can be costly at times.
Like Noah, he lost every Instagram follower he ever had, because he would not stop posting about that arc.
And yet he never wavered.
He never questioned if he was supposed to do it.
Why?
Like what would grip someone like this to do that?
It sounds so simple and yet it is still so true.
He loved God.
I remember when Brooke and I started dating, it made absolutely no sense.
Not because she is an amazing, she is
All out amazing.
It made no sense because I was a senior in college.
She was a freshman in college and I had my whole life already mapped out ahead of me.
I knew I was graduating and I was moving to take a new job into a new city.
And it was everything the likes of which I wanted to do.
And yet I couldn't get by the fact that I just had this loving feeling.
You know, I needed to be near this girl.
And so what I chose to do was incalculable to all of my peers.
It felt crazy to the world around me.
I chose to forgo a higher paying job in a better city fuller of opportunity so that way I could take a lesser paying job in a city that had virtually no opportunity because I wanted to be near to her.
You see, I knew things could be better in my life, but she could not be any better.
I wanted her.
And Noah feels the same way about God.
He's looking at his circumstances like, you know what?
Yeah, like people could be nicer and life could be easier, but God, God can't be any better.
He's everything that I want.
He's as good as it gets.
And I'm going with him no matter what the cost is.
He knows walking with God can be costly.
That's why it says of Noah, three specific things that he was righteous, blameless, and he walked with God.
It says that he was righteous, meaning he knew how to relate rightly to God.
In life,
You relate differently to different types of people.
The way you relate to your boss is different than the way you relate to your boyfriend, which is different than the way you relate to your parents, which is different than the way you relate to the male man, which is different than the way you relate to your neighbors.
To be righteous is to relate rightly to God.
No one knew how to do that.
It says that he was blameless.
That idea there is that his character was not flawed, like his inner man,
had integrity.
It's interesting, the Hebrew for that word blameless is the word tamim.
And when you read Solomon's construction of the temple, he was to use tamim stones, stones that had no crack or blemish.
They were to be blameless.
Your life is meant to be a blameless life.
And then it says that he walked with God.
Like when everyone was walking away from God, no one chose to walk with God.
He didn't pursue popularity.
He didn't need the approval of man.
He just wanted God.
That's all he wanted.
He wanted proximity.
And because of it, what we know is that as the world grieved the heart of God, Noah pleased the heart of God, which raises a big question in my mind.
How did he do it?
Like, how did Noah do what no one else could?
Well, it tells us, if you go to Hebrews 11,
Verse seven recounts to us a couple of things about Noah, but very one thing very specifically that's important around how he was able to do this.
It tells us by faith, Noah, being warned by God concerning events as yet unseen in reverent fear, constructed in art for the saving of his household.
You see, Noah was able to do it because he had a reverent, a holy fear.
He didn't act out of a fear of man.
He didn't worry what everybody was going to say, or what everybody was going to think.
He did not act out of a fear of the future, even though he had things he wanted to achieve.
He was not concerned with those.
He was concerned with God.
He did not act out of a fear of failure.
Well, what if I'm not able to achieve what God's asking me?
You know what?
Let me instead just try to preserve what I already have.
And he did not act out of a fear of discomfort.
Like he didn't just stay home, remain uncommitted, and binge watch the last three seasons of Survivor in prep for the 50th.
That's not what Noah did.
What Noah did is he feared God.
That's where his fear was found.
It was found in God.
And the reason we know that is because twice in this story, twice, it tells us that he did all that God commanded him, which is impressive because God asks a lot and God expects a lot and yet Noah delivered on all of it.
But that's not only why it's impressive.
You want to know why it's also even more impressive?
It is even more impressive because Noah did not know the specifics of how God intended to judge the world.
He knew God was going to bring judgment, but he had no idea what it was going to look like.
All he knew is God was asking him to build a big wooden boat.
And that's it.
He didn't have any clarity from God of what was to come.
He just knew that God had asked, which is so important because Noah reveals to us that we don't need a great reason to go.
We just need God's word.
When God asks, we respond.
Noah didn't need to be convinced that it was worth doing.
He didn't need to be persuaded that it was going to
Yield something, some kind of blessing in his life, and he did not need to worry about God, he did not need to worry about God preserving his reputation.
Instead, he just needed God to ask him.
That was reason enough.
And so I need you to listen to me on this.
I am so convinced for every single person in the room that God has asked us to do something.
I don't know where you're at in relationship to him.
I don't know if you've walked with him your whole life.
I don't know if you don't care about him at all.
But the truth of the matter is to every single person here, God has asked something of you.
There are no exceptions.
And yet some of you are waiting for God to give you all the details before you do anything about it.
God has asked you to be honest.
But you're waiting to see what's going to happen because your boss might actually fire you from your job if you come clean.
You know God has asked you to go into ministry, but you're waiting for him to tell you how he's going to preserve your lifestyle because you don't want to give up the things that you've got.
You know God has asked you to quit drinking, but you're worried about being quietly excluded from your friend group, and so you're hoping God will prove to you that you're not gonna have to give up what you have in order to be faithful instead.
You know that God has asked you to pursue purity, but God, like, what's that gonna mean for my relationship?
I really like him, I really like her.
Are we going to be able to keep this thing together?
Because we've bent some rules, we've compromised in the past, and I don't know if they're gonna like whatever parameters I have to offer.
Some of you, you know God has asked you to come to region.
And yet, you're not sure what it's gonna feel like to be 100% known and totally ousted in front of a group of strangers, and so you're waiting for him to reveal it.
Others of you, you know that God has looked at you and he has told you to keep the baby.
And yet, you don't know what that will mean for your future plans.
Others of you, you know that God is asking you to admit where and when you lied to those people.
But you're not sure what they're gonna think when you do, in fact, come clean, get honest, and tell the truth.
You see, and this one's so important because I think it is so prevalent.
We are often, instead of wanting for clarity of what God is going to give, we are wanting for certainty of what it's going to take.
You don't want clarity of what he's asking.
you want certainty of what that's going to require.
And yet here's the thing that we learn from this story and you need to know for your life.
God does not want you to move on facts.
He wants you to move on faith.
He does not want you to trust in your understanding of the circumstance.
He wants you to trust in your understanding of Him and His character.
He doesn't want you to
to move forward without looking back and remembering what we've learned about his character that God is gracious and he's merciful and he's kind and he's just and he's compassionate to people.
Because if you don't remember those things from the past what's gonna happen, you're gonna find yourself in a situation in the future where everything about your present circumstance is telling you God must not like you, God must have a grudge against you, God must in fact hate you.
And none of that is true because everything he's done before would disprove that that is reality.
And the reason we know it, for Noah and for ourselves is we can look to Jesus most of all and in Christ we can see someone who he walked with us at great cost to himself before we ever thought of walking with him at great cost of our own.
You see Jesus, he moved into your neighborhood.
He walked amongst you when you did not want him and he did so that way he might lay down his life and bring you into right relationship with himself and God forever.
And if he's willing to do that to walk with you
Even at great cost, we should equally be willing to walk with Him at great cost ourselves.
Last point, look at chapter 7 verse 11.
It says this, in the 600th year of Noah's life, in the second month, on the 17th day of the month, on that day, all the fountains of the great deep burst forth, and the windows of the heavens were opened, and rain fell upon the earth 40 days and 49s.
Jump down to verse 17.
The flood continued 40 days on the earth.
The waters increased and bore up the ark, and it rose high above the earth.
And the waters prevailed and increased greatly on the earth.
And the ark floated on the face of the waters.
And the waters prevailed so mildly on the earth that all the high mountains under the whole heaven were covered.
The waters prevailed above the mountains, covering them 15 qubits deep.
And all flesh died that moved on the earth.
Birds, livestock, beasts, all-swarming creatures that swarm on the earth and all mankind.
Everything on the dry land that whose nostrils was the breath of life died.
He blotted out every living thing that was on the face of the ground, man and animals and creeping things in birds of the heavens.
They were blotted out from the earth.
Only Noah was left and those who were with him in the ark and the waters prevailed on the earth 150 days.
Now when most people think of the flood narrative, this is the section that they think about.
They think about waters rising high and mountains sinking low and creatures drowning in the deep.
It's a really bleak image and it's really bad for God's PR.
How can he be good and lose it like this?
Is this a total overreaction in a necessary outrage, an irrational response to mankind's sin?
No.
God doesn't overreact to sin.
We underreact to it.
God does not overreact to sin.
We underreact to this.
You see, typically when we read this story, we question God's decision to flood the earth.
And yet we do that without ever asking how God arrived at that decision himself, which is completely unfair.
Like it's not right to take issue with God in the decision he's made.
If you're not willing to really consider why he would have made that decision.
And yet thankfully, this story tells us
Like we can find ourselves just in verse 12 of chapter six, reading God's own explanation for why he chose to do what he did.
You see, it says this, and I'm gonna read it to you from the NASB because I think that it helps us to understand much more clearly what's happening in the Hebrew.
So check out the screen, unless you have that in your lab.
It says this in verse 12, and God looked on the earth and behold, it was corrupt or ruined.
For humanity had corrupted or ruined its way upon the earth.
Then God said to Noah, the end of humanity has come before me, for the earth is filled with violence because of the people.
And behold, I'm about to destroy or ruin them with the earth.
Do you see what's happening here?
It says that humans have ruined their way on the earth, and they have ruined the land of the earth alongside it.
humanity's corruption is already leading to destruction.
And so what God does, knowing how this is going to inevitably play out, he hands humans over to the very things that they've already begun.
God is not the monster in the story.
We are.
I love the way Daniel Hawk commentator describes it.
He says it like this.
He says, the verse suggests that God has seen where the ruined nation of creation is headed.
And he's decided to accelerate the process to completion.
We're left with the sense that God is not so much sending the flood to punish the world as much as facilitating through the flood the inevitable descent into chaos caused by human destructiveness and violence.
God ruins an already ruined creation.
Do you see it?
And in so doing, he creates conditions for a reordering and a renewal to take place.
Which raises a really important question for us here at the end of our time.
Where in your life are you rebelling from God?
where you rebelling from him.
I know it's easy to ask that from stage and to even receive that from the seat and just kind of think to yourself some of the things you know you should not be doing, get you find yourself doing.
And yet here's the thing that I really want to lean into and I could give you a ton of mail as to what it looks like to rebel against God.
Like for some of you it's your sexual ethic.
You treat porn like it's some sort of normal self-expression.
You're cohabiting with someone and you have no kind of commitment.
You're redefining sex is purely recreational because your desire is to find what's right in your eyes.
I could tell you that it's your radical individualism.
No one gets to tell you who you are or what you do or how you get to be, which is a really dangerous place to live because it means that there is no authority in your life.
And when there's no authority, there's no accountability.
You are your own God.
I could tell you it's your egotism and your pride.
That you cut off people when they challenge you, you grow defensive.
When someone tries to correct you, you think you know better than others.
I could tell you that it's your goal-oriented idolatry because here's the thing, and this is particularly true for Christians.
Rebellion sometimes looks impressive.
And yet what you find is that your focus is on the money you make and the appearance you have and the influence you hold and it even bleeds into your religious reputation.
I can tell you it's your personal passivity.
This is such a prevalent issue in our day.
It's such a prevalent issue in our generation that we will use our personality type as some sort of exemption from godliness and obedience.
Let me just be real with you.
Holiness is not a personality type.
It's an expectation.
Who God is is who you should be.
You don't do that on your own power.
You do that by way of yielding to his spirit, by submitting to his work.
And often that begins by yielding to his work of conviction.
You respond whenever he comes a calling.
Here's why it matters that you identify where you're rebelling.
Your rebellion will lead to ruin.
Take a lesson from the dead.
That's what happens to them.
One man and his family make it out.
Everyone else, because they rebelled when the days grew dark.
They found themselves drowning in the deep, not of God's fury, but his passive wrath, giving them over to the very things that they wanted for themselves.
You see, sometimes the very thing that you want for yourself is not the best thing for yourself, but everything God wants for you, it is in fact the best thing for you.
you just need to receive it and respond.
Here's the fear that I have.
My greatest fear as I was prepping this is I could lay all this out to you.
But some of you, you're going to wait until it starts raining to repent.
You're going to hear the call of God in your life.
You're going to feel the conviction of his spirit.
And yet you're going to turn a deaf ear in a blind eye to what he's showing and speaking.
And it's going to take those first drops for you to, to add last repent.
And in that moment, it'll be too late.
It will be too late.
And yet what we know from this story,
is it's not God's fury that brings the flood.
It is his mercy.
He takes an already ruined situation, and he redeems out of it a brighter future by finding Noah.
And friend, he wants to do that with you.
But here's the thing with that.
Just as he was merciful then, he could be merciful today, but he will do for you what he did for them.
He will bring you to your end.
before he leads you to his beginning.
In that end, it always looks like repentance.
Last story and I'll get out.
I was in college whenever I learned the story of Johnny Eric Zintada.
If you're not familiar, Johnny was just 17 when she suffered a diving accident that left her paralyzed from the shoulders down.
And yet in the almost 60 years since that accident,
Johnny has used her story to teach not of God's fury against her, but his mercy towards her.
Here's what she says in her booklet, Hope the Best of Things.
I sure hope I can bring this will chair with me to heaven.
Now I know that's not theologically correct, but I hope to bring it and put it in a little corner of heaven.
And then in my new perfect glorified body, standing on grateful glorified legs, I'll stand next to my Savior holding his nail pierced hands.
I'll say, thank you, Jesus.
And he'll know what I mean because he knows me.
He'll recognize me from the fellowship we're now sharing in his sufferings.
And I'll say, Jesus, you see that will, Jer.
You were right when you said that in this world we would have trouble because that thing was a lot of trouble.
But the weaker I was in that thing, the harder I leaned on you.
And the harder I leaned on you, the stronger I discovered you to be.
It would never have happened had you not given me the bruising blessing of that wheelchair.
Friends, listen.
What may feel like punishment from God?
Here tonight, it may actually be an invitation to you instead.
because what we see from this story and what you need to know from your life is that God is not punitive in nature.
He is redemptive in nature.
And the reason we know that He is not wanting for your punishment is because He has laid that punishment on Himself.
He has put it on His Son.
You see, Jesus
has done all that we could not from when we were quick to blame God for not caring Christ who was blameless.
He proved how much he cared for us by pursuing us in life.
For though walking with God is costly at times Christ walked
with us at greatest cost to himself at even the cost of his own life.
And though we may underreact to sin, Christ has reacted rightly in that he came to do what we could not do.
He came to die where we deserve.
And he rose forth in victory.
So friend, if you feel like you're being punished by God, I would dare tell you you're being called by God.
And the first step is a step of repentance.
Let me pray that you would take that step tonight.
God, I love you, and I'm thankful for these people and thankful God that God, though I, and though we can be better, you, God, cannot be.
You are so good.
You are so faithful.
You are so kind.
And God, you are so very slow to anger.
You want all to come to the knowledge of your mercy.
You want all God to bend the knee in repentance.
So God, I'm asking that you would do that tonight.
I'm praying, God, that here in this moment, as we turn back to worship, you'd save us from stealing out of the room and racing into our evening.
You would save us from making excuses about why, God, we're not going to respond when we know it is you that is asking, that is calling, that is seeking.
I pray, God, you'd save us from ourself.
And for some of us God, that means tonight, we reach the end of ourselves that we find the beginning of you.
God, meet with us now, move amongst us, please.
And what we know, you are so very patient.
And God, we're meant to be so very repentant.
We love you.
It's in Christ's name we pray.
Amen.